und eine große Rolle dabei spielt
offenbar auch die Schweiz diese sollen
nämlich Züge und zwar voll mit
Flüchtlingen an die deutsche Grenze
bringen droht uns jetzt der asyl-kollaps
tausende illegale Migranten tausende
Menschen auf der Suche nach einem neuen
Zuhause tausende Menschen aus Syrien
Afghanistan und Nordafrika bilder wie
diese sie sind Zeugnis der gescheiterten
Asylpolitik Deutschlands und eine
Wiederholung der Fehler aus 2015 denn
nach Bildinformationen explodiert die
illegale Migration nach Deutschland
15.000
illegale Einwanderer wurden allein im
Oktober von der Bundespolizei
registriert knapp 500 Personen pro Tag
Tendenz steigend dazu kommen noch
dreimal so viele Migranten die nicht von
der Bundespolizei aufgegriffen werden
doch anstatt zu warnen anstatt die
Zahlen publik zu machen schweigt das
verantwortliche Bundesinnenministerium
von Innenministerin nennt sie Feser
kommt
nichts
sehnenauges hinein in die nächste
asylkatastrophe besonders brisant laut
Bildinformationen setzen Schweizer
Sicherheitsbehörden immer wieder bewusst
illegal Einreisende Afghanen Syrer und
Nordafrikaner Entzüge von der Schweizer
Ostgrenze in Richtung Deutschland die
offizielle Ansage der schweizerischen
Bundesbahn Migrantinnen und Migranten
welche weder eine Reservierung noch ein
Ticket besitzen sind auf die definierten
Züge des ir37 zu lenken heißt in der
Schweiz ankommende Flüchtlinge werden in
extra für sie organisierte Züge gesetzt
und durch die Schweiz gefahren
Endstation Basel also direkt an der
Grenze zu Frankreich und Deutschland von
dort aus können die Flüchtlinge illegal
und einfach nach Deutschland kommen die
Schweizer Behörden wissen die
Flüchtlinge wollen nicht in der Schweiz
bleiben zu teuer keine Perspektive
Einwanderer Ziel Nummer eins bleibt
weiterhin Deutschland bereits in der
vergangenen flüchtlingskrise die Schweiz
in der Kritik
illegale Einwanderer weiter nach
Deutschland reisen zu lassen dass die
Schweiz damit gegen geltendes Recht
verstößt davon wollen die Behörden
nichts wissen auch die SBB weist
jegliche Kritik von sich bezeichnet das
illegale durchwinken als
Transportauftrag doch nicht nur die
Schweiz lässt Deutschland mit Vollgas in
die asylkatastrophe laufen
EU-Beitrittskandidat Serbien
erleichterte erst vor kurzem seine
Visa-Vergabe heißt für Menschen aus
Syrien Afghanistan und Nordafrika ist es
deutlich einfacher auf die Balkanroute
zu kommen und somit zu uns schaffen wir
das zum Vergleich 2015 stellten 700.000
Personen einen Asylantrag in Deutschland
die Folgen für Städte und Kommunen
verheerend momentan befinden sich
bereits 900.000 ukrainische Flüchtlinge
in der Bundesrepublik und jetzt kommen
täglich unzählige illegale Flüchtlinge
aus Syrien Afghanistan und Nordafrika
dazu deutschland droht zu der
asylkollaps unterstützt von unseren
Partnerländern und gebilligt von unserer
Bundesregierung
[Musik]
ja und für die Polizeigewerkschaft sind
wir bereits mittendrin in einer neuen
flüchtlingskatastrophe dass das
Innenministerium die Zahlen verschweigt
für Manuel Ostermann Vize der
Gewerkschaft ist das bereits ein Skandal
für uns sagt
das macht mich auch einigermaßen
fassungslos warum man so intransparent
ist und warum soll man was verheimlichen
zunächst einmal geht es ja auch darum
dass Führungsebenen in den
Sicherheitsbehörden diese Zahlen
dringend benötigen und polizeidaktische
Maßnahmen vollziehen zu können und vor
allem macht sie auch dann deutlich wie
können wir den Städten und Kommunen
Aussichten geben wie Sie zukünftig
agieren können wie man einen geordnetes
Verfahren hinbekommt wo kommen die
Menschen denn her welchen rechtlichen
Status er wir in diese Menschen die nach
Deutschland kommen all das wird ja in
die hohle Hand gehalten es wird
überhaupt nicht transparent kommuniziert
und wir stellen uns selbstverständlich
die Frage warum das so ist
tja die Deutsche Polizeigewerkschaft
also fassungslos wir müssen darüber
sprechen im Studios Bild
tv-chefredakteur Klaus Strunz schönen
guten Morgen Klaus also wir haben
offensichtlich ein großes Problem es
kommen immer mehr Flüchtlinge heran und
das Innenministerium hat nichts Besseres
zu tun als die Zahlen zu verschweigen
was sagt das über unsere Regierung über
unsere Situation aus naja das die
Politiker die die Dinge in der Hand
haben aus der Vergangenheit nichts
gelernt haben für mich ist das neben dem
faktischen über das wir gleich sprechen
der eigentliche Skandal wir haben 2015
eine einzige
undurchsichtige Situation durch
massenhafte unkontrollierte Einwanderung
geschaffen danach haben sich alle
gedreht und gefunden haben gesagt es war
nicht so schlimm inzwischen war der
Stand es war ganz schlimm es ist ganz
schlimm es müssen alle darunter leiden
übrigens auch viele der Menschen die
eingereist sind müssen darunter leiden
in unzumutbaren
Zuständen Leben und dann ist es so sagen
wir mal ausgesessen worden statt sich
darum zu Kü das ist nicht wieder
passiert denn das ist wieder passieren
kann war allen Beteiligten klar das ist
also fast schon vorsätzlich wegschauen
und nicht handeln und jetzt wiederholt
sich Geschichte man sagt ja gern
geschichte wiederholt sich nie doch
Geschichte wiederholt sich jetzt an
diesem Beispiel weil Politiker aus ihren
Fehlern nichts gelernt haben oder noch
schlimmer es kann ich als Fehler erkannt
haben und Landräte und Bürgermeister die
schlagen Klaus ja schon lange Alarm
bitten um Hilfe bitten um mehr
Kontrollen bitten um
Gesetzesänderungen und hinzu kommt jetzt
eine Wirtschaftskrise wie steht der
Sozialstaat da jetzt mit dieser
Doppelbelastung naja erstmal es ist
prallt ja alles oder strömt alles stürzt
alles auf den Sozialstaat ein denn jeder
Mensch der hier kommt und Hilfe sucht
und Dingen Anspruch nimmt kostet Geld
das andere Leute einbezahlt haben das
macht jeder ja gern solange das System
austariert ist aber wir nehmen uns mal
ein einfaches Beispiel wenn du privat
eine Essensausgabe für Menschen
organisierst und es kommen immer mehr
und immer mehr dann brauchst Du immer
mehr und immer mehr essen und wenn du
das nicht mehr finanzieren kannst dann
kommt was auf ein Gefühl von
Ungerechtigkeit Verteilungskämpfe
Probleme Schwierigkeiten und irgendwann
sagst du hey leute wenn ihr mich so im
Stich lasst dann kann ich das nicht mehr
aufrecht halten und ich glaube dass
unserem Sozialstaat was ähnliches droht
wenn jetzt die bundesinnenministerin und
die verantwortliche rot-grüne würde ich
fast sagen aber halt das ist auch die
FDP noch dabei das vergesse ich immer
irgendwie also die rot-grün-gelbe
Regierung besser gesagt die grün rot
gelbe Regierung so stellt sich sie
eigentlich da also unser linke Regierung
wenn die nicht langsam auf die Bremse
tritt und hier sagt so kann es nicht
weitergehen man muss einmal sich ehrlich
machen und ist ja auch der Punkt den die
Polizeigewerkschaft da so auf die
Barrikaden bringen Dinge geschehen okay
wir haben jetzt versagt sie zu
verhindern jetzt sind sie da und jetzt
hilft eigentlich nur noch eins sie
ehrlich zu benennen ehrlich ehrlich zu
machen aufzulisten was wirklich ist um
dann sagen zu können so reagieren wir
darauf und dafür hat die
bundesinnenministerin jetzt natürlich
keine besonders große
vertrauenseinzahlung dadurch geleistet
dass sie die Zahlen für den September
mal ganz einfach auch intern schon nicht
veröffentlicht hat weil sie nämlich so
grausam sind da wird klar dass die
Immigration die Einwanderung die
illegale Einwanderung explodiert und
dass wir offensichtlich nicht in der
Lage sind damit klarzukommen aber das
ist doch ein Armutszeugnis wo die für
die Politik wo man sagt das wird
schwierig da mache ich einfach die Augen
zu und so ein bisschen wie bei Kindern
wenn man wenn ich sie nicht sehe dann
sehen sie mich auch nicht und jetzt sind
wir bei dem Punkt ich argumentiert das
alles ja nicht weil ich gegen Menschen
in Not bin oder weil ich ein ewiger
Gegner von von Ausländern bin oder sowas
ich Argument das ganze Gegenteil ist der
Fall ich argumentiere es aus Sorge um
unseren Sozialstaat es gibt kaum was
wichtigeres in diesem Land das unser
Leben so aufrecht erhält
wieder Sozialstaat dass wir es geschafft
haben alle miteinander dieses Land so zu
konstruieren dass wenn jemand den
notgerät Hilfe bekommt das niemand
wirklich komplett nach unten durchfällt
wird es in den allermeisten anderen
Staaten dieser Erde der Fall ist seine
riesen Errungenschaft und ich mache mir
große Sorgen dass die Menschen die das
mitgeholfen haben aufzubauen die dieses
Land mitgeholfen haben aufzubauen jetzt
das Gefühl haben sie haben mit dieser
Regierung Mieter in ihrem Haus dass sie
aufgebaut haben die dieses Haus kaputt
machen die dieses Haus entkernen und
wenn das passiert ist wenn das
Sozialstaat nicht mehr funktioniert die
ersten Maden und Warnsignale kommen ja
schon am Wochenende wurde bekannt dass
das Rentensystem so wie es ist
eigentlich nur noch fünf Jahre taugt
dann heißt es länger arbeiten länger
arbeiten länger arbeiten so haben die
Menschen die 30 40 Jahre aber einbezahlt
haben nicht gerechnet und so war sie
noch nicht versprochen das ist Betrug am
renteneinzahler wenn das so kommt und
wenn es da schon zu wanken beginnt dann
braucht es nur noch Schwierigkeiten
Arbeitslosenversicherung geben dann gibt
es immer höhere Beiträge zur
Krankenversicherung und dann ist der
Sozialstaat irgendwann soweit dass er
die Grätsche macht und wenn das passiert
wenn immer mehr Menschen den Glauben
verloren haben dass das was sie in den
Sozialstaat investiert haben nicht mehr
für Sie nützlich sein wird sondern für
irgendwen oder gar keinen mehr dann
mache ich mir wirklich Sorgen um den
inneren Frieden in dem Land wir haben
das schon
rauspitzen welches Zeugnis stellst du
der Ampel jetzt derzeit in dieser
Situation in dieser Lage aus gut die
Menschen haben ja testiert in einer
Umfrage für Bild haben Sie Olaf Scholz
mehrheitlich attestiert dass sie ihn für
überfordert halten dem kann man sich nur
anschließen ich glaube die Regierung
macht zurzeit eine denkbar schlechte
Figur weil wir sie immer öfter dabei
erwischen dass Sie uns einfach nicht die
Wahrheit sagen so wie jetzt auch bei der
ganzen Energie und AKW
frageck einfach nicht bei der Wahrheit
geblieben ist in einer zentralen Frage
so wie Frau Feser ich will jetzt würde
ich sagen uns nicht die Wahrheit sagt
aber zumindest uns nicht volle
Transparenz gibt wie es sich bei der
Migration verhält und jedes einzelne
Schweigen bedeutet immer deutlicher wer
schweigt oder verschleiert oder nicht
alle Fakten offenlegt der macht sich
eigentlich mit schuldig an dem was in
Zukunft passieren wird geschrieben wird
ja auch gegenüber der Schweiz zum
Beispiel das finde ich schon ganz schön
unfassbar dass da einfach die
Flüchtlinge im Busse gesetzt werden und
quasi durchgewunken bis zu uns und es
wird nichts gesagt obwohl die gegen
geltendes Recht verstoßen ist da gar
nichts angeschoben das ist neben dieser
Phaser schon sagen wir mal
intransparenzpolitik das was mich an
diesem Tag heute eigentlich am meisten
aufregt und zwar die Schweiz hat sich in
vielen großen historischen
Zusammenhängen schon schäbig Verhalten
das ist die nächste Episode in in dieser
unrühmlichen Schweizer Geschichte aber
es bedeutet noch was anderes an
offensichtlich hat die Weltgemeinschaft
die Europäische Gemeinschaft unsere
Nachbarländer wieder den Trottel
gefunden der alle aufnimmt also das ist
diese Schutz zu sagen wie Menschen die
Schutz suchen sind bei uns Schweizer
könnten Ihnen ja auch Schutz geben wir
könnten Ihnen ja auch was zu essen und
zu trinken geben wir könnten sie ja auch
bei uns aufnehmen nee nee nee nee nee zu
uns wollen die gar nicht weil bei uns
ist alles so teuer deshalb setzen wir
sie in Züge und Karren sie nach
Deutschland das ist eine Metapher für
dieses den gesamten Kollaps in dieser
Migrationssituation den am Ende wieder
Deutschland ausbadet denn wenn keiner
die Menschen aufnimmt dann kommen Sie am
Ende alle zu uns und das hält dieses
Land nicht aus sagt Klaus Strunz
btv-chefredakteur vielen herzlichen Dank
für Deinen Besuch heute im Studio
[Musik]